[Laughter]
[Applause]
whoa oh my god can I tell you something
yeah you had me on the edge of my seat
everyone sees why did you run straight
into the water I cannot believe you
pulled it off I know I wasn't decimated
the whole time people didn't know my
game people don't know my strategy and
it worked
Josh I don't want to ever go through
this dress everything either me neither
I called back you're gonna go through it
again you know what I loved about you I
loved that you were yourself yeah I
loved that you you you you gave it your
all and your cue to yourself even if you
were crying banging pots and pans that's
who I am that's why I mean I can't
change that I'm not gonna change that in
the Big Brother house for $500,000 and I
think that's what got me to the end
being myself being on it speaking my
mind singing how it is I mean we got ICO
who did the same thing and it worked
so I played out good for me you know I
knew I was gonna see you today and I'm
like oh my god you know I brought you a
box of tissue it's great all season Josh
interview oh my god okay so I'm watching
the final show and you take Paul and I'm
like or you straight wheats I'm like
don't do it
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing obviously this is the
thing that people didn't understand me
and Paul pissed off the same amount of
people in the house Christmas did
everything literally with kindness she
killed everybody with kindness she put
people on the block and I felt like she
was hanging in done 500k I'm like I
can't sit next because she's so like I
knew that I played a better game but I
thought that people are gonna be bitter
you know so but I knew that we pissed
off the same people not only that my
game was so underestimated and the shock
value of me being a super fan I knew it
would throw people off and also I had
gbm's and I had my final speech he was
playing his game and I respected it but
I was playing my game too and he didn't
know that I was saying it how was yes I
actually love that like I loved that in
the dr's
you would be like well this is what
really happens guys that's game that's
that shade that's game people are saying
it's shady it's coward but I heard I
heard that I was getting all the
everything tossed on me I heard that it
was like oh I'm sorry that they did that
they went rogue I'm like well really I
was just being honest but you know
everybody played their game it's done I
love them both dearly and yeah I can't I
was like oh my god Josh she gave me
stress and anxiety and you know you know
I don't get anxiety you know you know
back you had me stressed out I have an
anxiety don't do it again I won't do it
again
I was like Josh remember you have
pigeons my dogs I got away I'm so happy
for you they're like all that I played
that I only had you routed from them
like the real ones that's it everybody
else played themselves good you know I I
remember I was like still keeping hope
alive my face
Mike I'm gonna root for you as you're
like really yeah you did day one before
I jumped in the house she's like I'm a
room for you I like you you're a real
one and now we're here I can't ask you
today why Dubai